I'm going to play a quick Montage of
some right-of-center media figures and
podcasters sharing their criticisms he
was just being mean well I was going to
say like what what he is saying is
actually genuinely like really mean
Parts yeah the whole thing is true like
it's not it's not like it's untrue I
will absolutely say yeah it's mean yeah
Matt Walsh is being mean major divide on
this video is whether or not the
language was a little too harsh
factually he's not wrong no factually
yeah
I eat I don't look if your job is to win
hearts and Minds
I don't think this is the best way of
doing it you'll notice the connecting
thread they all agree that I'm right
that what I said is factually correct so
they think that it goes too far by
saying it out loud well see this is
where we differ I don't think it's
possible to go too far by speaking truth
the truth is the truth it is what it is
are we gonna defend it or are we going
to conceal it are we going to embrace it
are we going to hide from it you can't
have it both ways